something tells me there may have been
some film Theory fans working on the set
of the new Sonic movie remember in the
trailer when they showed sonic running
past a radar gun and it returned a value
of seven hundred and sixty miles per
hour
well that trailer clip prompted me to
respond with this video where I looked
at the reality of radar guns coming to
the conclusion that no gun would be able
to reach a speed that high and that the
radar would instead cap out around 200
miles per hour and wouldn't you know it
the scene was changed in the final movie
where Sonic's new speed clocks in around
250 to 300 miles an hour coincidence
maybe but then how do you explain the
scene when Robotnik out of the blue just
encourages Sonic to slow down telling
him that a speed is dangerous for his
joints they proved it you know is
exactly what he says now who is this
they Eggman could it be us I mean we did
dedicate an entire episode to whether
Sonic's body could survive his own
extreme speeds concluding that it's
ultimately bad for his joints undersand
there were more than a few parallels to
our past sonic episodes and I'm not mad
by any means in fact I'm kind of
flattered but next time you could at
least invite me to the premiere now if
you'll excuse me I'm off to feed my
sadness with this never ending pasta
bowl from Olive Garden hello Internet
welcome to film theory where I'm here to
remind you Sonic turned his life around
in one year you can too
today I'd like to start by
congratulating the team working on the
sonic movie well done guys you managed
to do the impossible like three times
over by my calculations in one movie you
managed to one create a good video game
movie to take the criticism of the
internet rage machine and use it to
better your film and three make a kid's
movie with a minimal amount of cringe I
mean Kevin Sonic floss not just once but
twice was starting to push your luck a
bit there but you know what I'll give
you the benefit of the doubt I'd like to
think of it as a call back to the days
when Sonic had to maintain his weird
little human-like teeth mean why floss
when you can floss but seriously I had a
lot of fun with this movie it was a
perfect balance of original storytelling
and fan service the subtle references to
Chaos Emeralds the Sega Saturn the
music from the game some of Sonic's
iconic poses the fact that his punch is
about as effective as being slapped
across the face with a flaccid noodle I
mean you even managed to keep some of
the big cameo reveal secret including
what was to me the highlighted movie the
guest appearance of sanic I mean how
would you pull that one out of your egg
sack Eggman but don't let that comedic
Lee oversized head get any bigger their
Sonic Team because today can't be all
about praise thank you for some things
first off blatant product placement
Raziel oh come on we all know that truly
Oz where it's that fam what what
actually to be fair any smart apartment
shopper would be wise to use all the
major resources available to them so
then there's long haul the owl let me
get this straight you made up a new
character for this movie this is a
franchise where there's more throwaway
characters than Game of Thrones and you
just added to the pile instead of taking
an established one I mean I guess it
follows in the great tradition of the
fandoms o'seas
the only thing missing with Longclaw was
a watermark overhead reading do not
steal in all caps but it's the last pic
I have that I want to focus on for
today's episode you know a small teeny
tiny little problem I have with the
entire premise of the movie sonic drops
his rings through a magic portal and
they end up in San Francisco so he and
his human buddy Tom need to get them
back via a road trip you took the video
game character known for running real
fast and you put him in a truck for a
road trip
going like 65 miles an hour oh sure you
make the excuse that Sonic can't find
San Francisco and yeah I get that the
entire road trip was a veiled excuse for
sign like to connect with humans in a
way that he always longed to but was
unable to because of his self-imposed
isolation I get it but I just don't tear
as I crashed into the cold dark water of
the Pacific I realized a few things I
have no idea where I'm going and clearly
I'm not gonna be able to do this on my
own don't sell yourself too short there
Sonic I have a pretty good feeling that
you would have been just fine left on
your own so today we're putting that
movie's premise to the test with Sonic's
roadtrip with Tom a faster way of them
getting to San Francisco than Sonic just
running there by himself No
what we know about sonic speed as well
as his apparent inability to use a basic
math with Sonic blindly running across
the country ultimately get him to San
Francisco faster than hopping in the old
Chevy Silverado and driving their human
style so let's start off with what we
know in the movie their entire road trip
takes roughly two days first night a
Sonic's big night out eating chili dogs
at the local biker bar by the late
afternoon of the next day they're in San
Francisco eatin clam chowder and
fighting off Robotnik but I want to
double check that figure seems like it's
a bit too short we know that their
journey begins in Green Hills Montana a
fictional city that apparently isn't all
that far off from the world's largest
rubber band Falls a clue that you think
might help us identify the real world
location of Green Hills but it doesn't
the largest rubberband ball in the world
was made in Lauderhill Florida and now
lives in a museum just a couple of
states away from Montana
I mean Sonic could be seeing a sign for
the world's second largest rubberband
ball a 175,000 band behemoth that lives
in Eugene Oregon but it's still too
early in the road trip for them to be
all the way over here when they started
somewhere in Montana so you know what
maybe we're better locating green hills
using another method according to the
welcome sign for green hills the city
has a population of 1981 and an
elevation of 3445 feet now finding a
place in western montana that fits both
of those criteria is surprisingly
challenging because the Rocky Mountains
are going right through that part of the
country elevations tend to be higher on
average they're 4,500 feet enough but by
cross-referencing Montana elevation maps
with Montana population maps I was able
to roughly pick out Howell County and
specifically the city of Deer Lodge as
our prime candidate for the real world
equivalent of green hills with an
elevation of 4500 yeah it isn't exact
but it's pretty darn close and about as
close as you're gonna find in this part
of Montana what also helped me settle on
Deer Lodge was this moment in the movie
when Robotnik is tracking Tom and Sonic
down we see red dots marked out on the
map presumably key areas that they
visited along the trip and the starting
dot is roughly here right where Idaho
has that first little chunk in the state
so track
that over and boom we're back in Powell
County so citizens of Deer Lodge all
3,000 of you who are clearly watching
this show no longer will your city just
be known as the home for the Montana
State Prison really jeez that is a
bummer of a thing to be known for well
all of you watching from your little
prison TVs while you're stamping out
license plates take pride knowing that
you are now the featured city of a
pretty okay video game movie anyway
using Google Maps to calculate the
length of the road trip from Deer Lodge
to San Francisco we see that there are
two possible routes the northern route
going up through Washington and down
through Oregon and another more direct
route headed down through Idaho and
Nevada again going back to Robotnik's
map that I mentioned earlier it seems
like Tom took the northern and longer
route we see red dots in both of those
Northwest states plus when Robotnik
zooms in on map he's looking at Southern
Oregon which again isn't anywhere close
to the southern route so knowing this we
see that it's an eighteen and a half
hour road trip from Deer Lodge to San
Francisco
pretty aggressive for a two-day road
trip but it's certainly not impossible
it's actually a lot faster than I
expected so now the question is would
sonic have been able to blindly find San
Francisco in that same 18 and a half
hour time or was the road trip
unbelievably a more efficient way of
getting him to his final goal we know
for a fact that Sonic can read in the
opening montage of his life on earth we
see him reading stacks of flash comic
books he also knows that his rings wound
up in San Francisco because he read it
on Tom's skin-tight t-shirt so it's less
of an issue of Sonic not knowing where
San Francisco is when he sees it but
more of him just needing help finding
the city outright in the first place now
I'm gonna assume that he isn't reading
road signs to follow directions or mile
markers we're just gonna assume that
once he reaches the city if he manages
to reach San Francisco he'll be able to
visually see the Transamerica building
where his rings landed because it's just
such a recognizable piece of
architecture so now how do we calculate
the odds of him finding San Francisco in
the first place well I propose that we
do it by working under the assumption
that he's just gonna run every Street in
America until he finds it just a bunch
of trial and error
brute force his way around the country
till he finally sees a sign that says
welcome to San Francisco or even better
just winds up at the foot of the tower
which of course as any sonic episode
does leads us to the inevitable question
of Sonic's speed now last time I covered
the sonic movie we calculated that Sonic
was running near the speed of light it's
the only way he'd be able to emit an
electromagnetic discharge capable of
shutting off power grids and
interrupting satellite flight but let's
not go to that extreme of a speed just
yet let's give the movie the best chance
it has at winning this little road race
right at the start of their adventure
shortly after Tom and Sonic escaped
green hills hum kick sonic out of the
truck telling him to find San Francisco
on his own prompting the scene that I
played earlier sonic runs west just like
tom tells him and he crashes into the
Pacific Ocean and then runs back with a
fish on his head now timing this scene
out yes I actually had a stopwatch in
the feeder so not only was I the weird
single guy in a room full of families
and small children but I was also the
weird single guy in a room full of
families and small children carrying a
stopwatch and using it during the movie
but from the moment he takes off to the
moment he returns to the truck it takes
exactly 3.9 seconds I'm just gonna round
this to four just to make the
calculations a bit more simple it's
taken to four seconds I have a challenge
where you got to go fast can you in the
time that it took Sonic to run from
green hills to the Pacific Ocean and
back bring the subscription bell and
leave a comment down below that you
can't let's test it out shall we
four three two
did you do it well whether you did or
didn't just know that your subscription
is appreciated we're trying to get to
ten million subscribers sometime this
year on this channel and I need all the
help I can get so you subscribing means
hola
thank you so much now on with the
episode if he took Tom's advice
literally sonic ran straight west to the
Pacific and then back in that amount of
time drawing a straight line from Deer
Lodge out to Pacific you see that at
this point they're about 550 miles or
885 kilometers away from the ocean that
means in four seconds Sonic traveled
1,100 miles or 1770 kilometers that's
275 miles or 442 kilometers a second or
our final number of nine hundred and
ninety thousand miles an hour 1.6
million kilometers an hour now hub gives
sonic the instructions of head west so
let's do that let's assume that Sonic
explores every roadway west of where he
currently is in green hills Montana
that's mostly gonna be the states of
Idaho Washington Oregon California a bit
more of Montana and Nevada so I added up
all of the roadways both paved and
unpaved for all of those states and
found that we're dealing with about 1
million 83,000 miles worth of roadway
1.7 million kilometers sonic would be
able to cover all of that in a little
over an hour but ok maybe sonic doesn't
know what direction west is maybe he
goes the wrong way well across all 50
states the US has 4 million 90 2729
miles of roadway six point five eight
million kilometers it is far and away
the best longest most robust road system
in the world and Sonic would be able to
cover it all in four hours giving him
more than enough time to get lost double
back and stop for every giant rubber
band ball that he sees along the way
while still making it to the
Transamerica building three times over
before Tom's truck would and remember
that's still me assuming the worst-case
scenario that sonic not traveling at
light speed not reading road signs that
Sonic traveling all the roads in America
before finally stumbling across San
Francisco has his bear
last destination cuz you know one of the
nation's largest cities might be hard to
miss but you know I call me Angelica
Skyler cuz I am still not satisfied what
if Sonic got really really lost and took
a road way that went south of the border
or up to Canada or maybe he just wanted
to enjoy a nice huevos rancheros near
the Nazca lines
so I tallied up all the roadways in all
the countries and territories of both
North and South America because I didn't
feel like separating out the island
nations to be honest so I went the whole
nine yards and I got myself seven
million twenty nine thousand three
hundred and six miles of roadway eleven
point three million kilometers seven
hours and six minutes worth of sonic run
time to run every Street every roadway
both paved and unpaved in every piece of
land in all of North and South America
and still still he is taking up less
than half the time it would require for
Tom to drive him that eighteen and a
half hour road trip so yeah I went there
because I'd already come this far why
not go the final step I went to the
CIA's World Factbook and added up all
215 entries they had for the roadways
around the world paying attention to
every last number even to lose little
reported eight kilometers of paved
roadway because that's how type a I am
an absolutely tedious process of data
crunching that was rendered entirely
useless when I got to the final four
entries of that CIA list and saw that
world was a separate entry unto itself
why would you put that at the top of the
list CIA or at the very least the very
bottom I know that you watch this show
because you're nervous about the things
that are in my search history from
researching the series so come on guys
use some basic data entry best practices
for me alright anyway I came up with
well I came up with a little more than a
half of what they reported as the world
total not 100% sure how it happened to
be honest I think they counted the
European Union twice in their
calculations because their numbers just
don't make sense relative to what
they're reporting Central Intelligence
Agency my foot more like crappy
information archive and that my friends
is why it pays to be thorough and
double-check government organizations
with your own Excel spreadsheet
Arlis my final total for all the
roadways in the world was 25 million ten
thousand four hundred thirty two miles
40 point two five million kilometers a
distance that would take sonic one day
and one hour to run meaning that finally
finally we've reached number that Tubbs
roadtrip is able to beat tourism
remember we said that eighteen and a
half hours was Tom's trip if he drove
non-stop but we know that they took
breaks they beat up biker thugs they
farted around in their hotel room
figuratively and literally in total that
road trip was at least a day and a half
probably 36 to 40 hours total before
everything is said and done meaning that
sonic running every roadway in the world
would still end up taking a shorter time
than sitting shotgun next to Tom down
the old route 90 west and again remember
this is me taking the conservative
estimate on every step along the way
here we're not even factoring in his
ability to travel near the speed of
light and don't you get started on me
about how they needed Tom to smuggle him
to the top of the building when he got
there at the start of the road trip they
didn't know that little bit of
information and as sonic and Eggman
chase each other through the city in the
opening sequence of the movie we see
Sonic's ability to literally run up the
exterior walls of buildings sure it's an
external view very wide out from the
action but still he is scaling the
building like a champ it's almost as if
the whole thing was manufactured by
Sonic to make Tom feel important in the
first place that manipulative little
Hedgehog seems like speed isn't his only
super ability so there you have it my
little chaotix you should watch the
sonic movie for a lot of reasons it's
fun it's funny it does the characters
justice just don't roll in expecting a
premise that makes a whole lot of sense
for an accurate location of the world's
largest rubberband ball or an appearance
from Charmy the B come on guys you make
Longclaw but you neglect charlie the
beach time to fire up the internet rage
machine one more time for the sequel but
first have to shop for an apartment
Zil
but hey that's just a theory
Oh film theory and cuts
[Music]
you